Коли гітлерівська армія зайшла в Київ, Юрію Фуксу було п'ять років.
Про ті часи він пам'ятає не багато. Розбиті вітрини магазинів, масові обшуки, пограбування та переслідування.
Ті трагічні події забрали життя усієї родини Фукса.
Дідусь Йосип, бабуся Фаня, батько на фронті, мама Лариса і сестра Людмила.
Це всі з моєї родини…
29 вересня 1941 року командування "СС" та поліцаї оголосили про масовий збір євреїв.
Хто не прийде - смерть.
Євреї мали взяти із собою документи та найцінніші речі.
Ходили чутки, що їх відправлятимуть до Палестини.
Тож люди з клунками виходили якомога раніше, аби першими бути в черзі на маршрут, який потім назвуть "дорогою смерті".
На збори пішли бабуся і дідусь Юрія. Натомість мама з дітьми переїхала в інший район Києва.
Її та молодшу сестру Юрія поліцаї забрали через півроку.
Доля моя полягає в тому, що в той день, коли за нами прийшли поліцаї,
я був у квартирі сусідки Марії Григорівни, а сестра з мамою в нашій квартирі.
Коли Марія Григорівна побачила у вікно, що йдуть поліції в наш барак, то вона зрозуміла, що це за нами, більше нікого не було...
Вона мене заховала. Але вони до нас навіть не стукали, вони забрали маму з сестрою і пішли.
З кожним роком свідків винищення євреїв у Києві стає дедалі менше.
5 років тому DW спілкувалася з іншої очевидицею трагедії - Раїсою Майстренко.
Однак нині поганий стан здоров'я не дозволив жінці знову зустрітися з DW.
Вона була однією з тих, хто йшов в колонах євреїв до Бабиного Яру.
Люди галасували, казали, що всіх ведуть розстрілювати і нас поведуть, давайте не кричати…
Жінка заледве стримувала емоції, згадуючи про ті події...
Бабуся завжди мовчала про це, ніколи не говорила, вона не хотіла травмувати мене.
Як вона ходила, як вона тут була...
Тому серйозно я почала розуміти цю трагедію, лише коли мені виповнилося 50 років.
Жодної світлини чи речі на згадку про найрідніших людей у Юрія Фукса не залишилося.
Місцем пам'яті хотів би бачити меморіальний комплекс в Бабиному Яру.
Я вважаю, що обов'язково потрібно побудувати, обов'язково.
Навіть справа не в євреях, а сам факт масового знищення беззахисних людей.
Що вони могли зробити, якщо їх пускали по десять людей і тут же роздягали і далі під конвоями вели...
Дискусії про будівництво меморіалу в Бабиному Яру,
де в часи окупації, за різними оцінками, було страчено від 70 до 200 тисяч людей, точаться вже багато років.
Історик та голова Всеукраїнської асоціації євреїв Борис Забарко вже втомився рахувати
численні спроби будівництва музею та обіцянки від політиків довести справу до кінця.
Я бачив і читав обіцянки всіх президентів - і всі вони не виконувалися.
Держава не включилася в цю роботу так, як це відбувається в інших країнах.
У США музей у Вашингтоні будувався довго, три президенти змінювали один одного, але продовжували в одному напрямку роботу над музеєм.
І створили такий важливий інститут. А в нас ні…
Нинішній проєкт увічнення пам'яті жертв трагедії політики озвучили 5 років тому,
під час вшанування 75-х роковин трагедії.
Тоді оголосили про створення Меморіального центру Голокосту "Бабин Яр"
та озвучили перший кошторис проєкту - понад 100 мільйонів доларів.
Забарко, свідок Голокосту та автор  багатьох наукових історичних статей та книг,  хотів би,
аби цей проєкт нарешті реалізували.
Я наполягаю на тому, щоб його нарешті побудували.
За цю роботу вже взялася сильна, професійна і кваліфікована авторська група науковців з України та інших країн.
Утім, у цього проєкту - багато критиків. Серед них -
ще один представник єврейської громади в Україні, голова Асоціації єврейських організацій і громад Йосиф Зісельс.
Це російський проєкт меморіалізації Бабиного Яру, де є окремий епізод, так звана Меморіальна синагога.
Я кажу про весь проєкт, це похідна від гібридної війни, яку Росія веде проти України.
Просто це не на фронті на Донбасі, а це є інформаційний фронт, у якого є своя ділянка.
Втручання у формування нашої культури і політики пам'яті.
Україна заслуговує на свою суб'єктність і на свій суверенітет у будь-якому питанні.
Річ у тому, що серед перших донорів проєкту були російські олігархи Михайло Фрідман, Герман Хан
та Павло Фукс, який має українське громадянство.
Однак арт-директор майбутнього меморіалу "Бабин Яр", теж росіянин Ілля Хржановський категорично відкидає таку критику.
Я вважаю, що це чиста маніпуляція, тому що цей проєкт, звісно, не російський.
Це проєкт міжнародний і український.
Усі, хто бере участь у цьому проєкті, його засновники, донори чи ті, хто працюють у ньому, -
в основному це громадяни України і громадяни інших країн.
І всі ми, кого пов'язують з Росією, маємо українське коріння.
80 років тут нічого не відбувалося. А тепер відбувається. Ми робимо проєкт передусім про любов.
Попри дискусії щодо нового меморіалу окремі елементи проєкту в Бабиному Яру вже споруджені.
Торік до річниці масових розстрілів відкрили аудіовізуальну інсталяцію з металевих колон,
наскрізь прострілених сотнею тисяч куль того ж калібру, якими вбивали людей у Бабиному Яру.
Крізь кульові отвори проходить світло та звук пам’яті...
Також у травні цього року в Бабиному Яру з'явилася синагога за проєктом німецько-швейцарського архітектора.
У закритому вигляді конструкція висотою 11 метрів нагадує велетенську книгу.
А відкриваючись, за 10 хвилин перетворюється у 100 метровий відкритий простір дерев'яної синагоги.
Художники відтворили на стінах синагоги малюнки і тексти молитов з єврейських храмів Західної України XVII-XVIII століть.
А стелю синагоги прикрашає зображення карти зоряного неба, яким воно було 29 вересня 1941 року.
Крім того, команді дослідників з Центру просторових технологій, які співпрацюють з Меморіальним центром
Голокосту "Бабин Яр", за допомогою новітніх технологій вдалося встановити місце масової страти та показати у 3D,
як Бабин Яр виглядав у 1941 році.
Їхні джерела - старі мапи, свідчення очевидців, аерозйомка німецької розвідки та світлини
фотографа Вермахту Йоганнеса Геле - єдині фотосвідоцтва жахливого злочину.
Щоправда, як виглядатиме сам музей - головна будівля Меморіального центру Голокосту "Бабин Яр" - досі невідомо.
Для Юрія Фукса це сумна новина.
Чесно кажучи, мені страшенно прикро, що вже 80 років після трагедії минуло, і нічого не робиться…
Обов'язково потрібно і хотілося б дожити до цього часу.
Він дуже сподівається, що ще за життя встигне побачити меморіальний комплекс.
На жаль, більшість свідків трагедії цього так і не дочекалися…